[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I am so pleased to welcome
you to this year's Julia S.
Phelps Lecture in the
Arts and Humanities.
Here at Radcliffe, we
have a twofold mission--
to support pathbreaking research
and creative endeavors across
all disciplines, and to share
that work with the public
through a full calendar
of events like today's.
Today, we are gathered for
the annual Phelps lecture
in honor of Julia S. Phelps.
Julia was a Radcliffe
College graduate
who worked as an art
historian, a curator,
and a devoted teacher.
Recent Phelps lectures have
featured cultural historian
and Boston Globe classical
music critic, Jeremy Eichler;
choreographer Karole Armitage;
and author ZZ Packer.
We are grateful to
Julia's family, friends,
and colleagues for
their generosity
and their support
in honor of Julia.
And let me offer a special
welcome to Julia's daughter
and son-in-law, Susan Napier
and Steven [? Coit, ?]
who are here in the
audience with us today.
[APPLAUSE]
This year's Phelps lecturer,
Marilynne Robinson,
is one of the most
distinctive voices
in contemporary
American literature.
She is in the midst of
a week here at Radcliffe
as a visiting
scholar, interacting
with students and faculty
across the university.
And this afternoon, Marilynne
will be in conversation
with another member
of the Harvard
community, the distinguished
literary critic, James Wood.
To have Marilynne and
James here together
is a fitting culmination to
a semester during which we
have enjoyed a feast
of brilliant writers,
including Viet Thanh Nguyen,
Gish Jen, Claudia Rankine,
Jhumpa Lahiri, and Celeste Ng.
And all of those events are
available through our website
if you'd like to
watch the videos.
At a time when our society is
preoccupied with what is real
and what is fake, when the
very notions of truth and fact
are under threat, it might
seem strange to celebrate
the virtues of fiction.
But I don't think it is.
Fiction has a remarkable
power to illuminate complexity
in action, motivation,
sensibility,
and emotion that we
might otherwise struggle
to understand or to articulate.
In fact, at a time when
supposedly objective observers
openly promote what
they know to be
false with the explicit
intention of misleading,
great fiction can help
to ground us in the real.
In today's world,
fiction can indeed
be stranger than
so-called truth.
Marilynne Robinson's
particular approach
to truth-telling through
fiction is especially powerful.
Reviewers of Marilynne's
work have all but
exhausted the range of
laudatory superlatives.
Her debut novel, Housekeeping,
is widely considered a classic
and has earned a place on The
Guardian's list of the 100
greatest novels of all time.
Marilynne's writing
is also so distinct
that critics have
struggled to pinpoint
its literary antecedents.
The well-known
sportswriter Allen Barra
stepped outside of
his typical milieu
to write a glowing review in The
Atlantic, in which he described
Marilynne as, and I quote,
"an American original."
He continued, and I quote
him, "Though Robinson
may share certain sensibilities
with other writers,
it's difficult to detect
more than a faint association
between her work and that
of any previous author."
James Wood, Marilynne's
conversation partner
who's here with us today, has
identified some of those shared
sensibilities, including a
familiar American simplicity
with its origins in
puritanism, as well as
echoes of Emerson and Melville.
But he, too, notes that the
final composition is unique,
especially among those
authors whose work
resonates with modern readers.
As James put it,
referring specifically
to Marilynne's Pulitzer
Prize-winning novel Gilead,
and I quote, "The result is
one of the most unconventional,
conventionally popular
novels of recent times."
Although Marilynne is best
known for her fiction,
she also writes
meticulously-researched
nonfiction on an incredible
range of subjects.
As a result, her body of
work resists our inclination
to pigeon-hole.
How do you sum up an
oeuvre that includes
both entrancingly quiet
literary novels like Gilead,
as well as a notable polemic
on nuclear waste entitled
Mother Country--
Britain, the Welfare State
and Nuclear Pollution?
Much of Marilynne's work in
both fiction and nonfiction
explores complex existential
and epistemological themes.
Religion-- in particular,
Marilynne's own Protestant
Christian faith--
figures prominently,
and it is treated
with a level of
grace and nuance that
is extremely uncommon in
broadly-read contemporary
literature.
Marilynne's writing
also challenges
us to reconsider
notions so embedded
in our collective
consciousness that we might not
be aware of them at all.
In her most recent
collection of essays
titled What Are We Doing
Here?, Marilyn writes,
and I quote, "In
essential ways, we
share false assumptions
and flawed conclusions that
are never effectively examined
because they are indeed
shared."
More sardonically,
Marilyn once observed
that "unread books
may govern the world,"
referring here to our
failure to critically assess
the fundamental texts on which
so much of modern culture
is based.
Some of Marilynne's
fictional characters
seem to embody the kind
of rigorous thought
that she demands of her readers.
For instance, the
Reverend John Ames,
who is the compelling
narrator of Gilead,
demonstrates a Christian faith
that is deeply held but still
questioning in important ways.
He is keenly aware of what
he doesn't fully understand.
At one point, Reverend
Ames writes to his son,
alluding to a passage in the
Gospel of Mark, and I quote,
"You can know a thing to death
and be, for all purposes,
completely ignorant of it."
In short, Marilynne pushes us
to think carefully about what we
know and believe
and what we don't.
In her essays, she does that
directly by boldly reassessing
the likes of John Calvin
and Charles Darwin,
or by examining the
contemporary topics
like tribalism,
cynicism, and the state
of American democracy.
But even more remarkable is
the way her novels grapple,
at least tangentially, with many
of the same intellectual issues
while engaging readers on both
cerebral and emotional levels.
And these novels do it
without seeming pedantic
or pedagogical.
That is the power
of great fiction.
Marilynne has spent
the bulk of her career
at the University of
Iowa's Writers' Workshop,
where she is now
professor emeritus.
In addition to the titles
I already mentioned,
Marilynne has written
two other novels--
Home, which won the
Orange prize; and Lila,
winner of the National
Book Critics Circle Award.
In nonfiction,
besides Mother Country
and What Are We Doing
Here?, Marilynne
is the author of The Death
of Adam, Absence of Mind,
When I Was a Child I Read Books,
and The Giveness of Things.
Among her honors, which are
too many to name here now,
Marilynne won the
Library of Congress Prize
for American Fiction in 2016.
She also received the 2012
National Humanities Medal,
awarded by President
Barack Obama for,
and I quote, "her grace and
intelligence in writing."
Now, it should be said
that this was not just
a matter of her turn coming up.
Rather, President Obama is
one of her greatest fans.
When Marilynne retired from the
Iowa Writers' Workshop in 2016,
President Obama recorded
a touching video message
to thank her for, and
I quote, "uncovering
what is most meaningful
when the rest of us
can't find the words."
James Wood is an ideal
conversation partner
for Marilynne, and I am
delighted to have him
here with us today as well.
James is one of the most admired
literary critics working today
and an author in his own right.
He has also been
called, and I quote,
"the foremost literary
enthusiast of our time."
James is a powerful
advocate for fiction
that is both aesthetically
beautiful and real.
He alludes to this commitment
in the title of his most
recent collection
of essays on fiction
which borrows its title from
a George Eliot quotation,
"Art is the nearest
thing to life."
James is professor of the
practice of literary criticism
here in the English
department at Harvard,
as well as a staff writer and
book critic at the New Yorker,
and a member of the
editorial board of the London
Review of Books.
James was previously a senior
editor at The New Republic
and chief literary
critic at The Guardian.
In addition to his collections
of critical essays,
James has published a novel
entitled The Book Against God
and a book-length study
of literary fiction called
How Fiction Works.
We are very
fortunate today to be
able to listen in as these
two stellar writers converse
with each other.
Before I invite them
up to the stage,
let me just tell you how
the afternoon will work.
Following the conversation
that they will have,
there will be time for
a Q&A when you, too,
can join the discussion.
We'll place a microphone
in this center aisle.
Please, if you have a question,
line up, introduce yourself
before you ask your question.
And afterwards, I invite you
all to a reception next door
at Fay House.
Now please join me in giving
a warm welcome to Marilynne
Robinson and James Wood.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much for
coming, and thank you to Liz
for that wonderful introduction.
I think the last thing you want
to do on a Tuesday afternoon
is hear two introductions.
So that's not going to happen.
I think we should go
straight into our discussion.
And I want it to
be free-flowing.
I think there were certain
things I might come back to--
obviously, fiction.
I think there might be some
interesting relationship
between us, perhaps even
tension at some point
because I had a very
religious upbringing
and I sort of came out the
other side from Marilynne
in some ways.
But we overlap in a
mutual respect, I think.
And of course, I have
an intense respect
for her writing, her
essays, and her fiction.
In addition to
the novels, I hope
that we will talk a little
bit, too, about her latest
book, a book of lectures,
as I was saying to Marilynne
earlier, an astonishing
book in itself
given how many lectures
she's written in the last two
or three years and how
superbly they maintain
the style of her essay.
So most of us, lectures
are hopeless things
full of oral clatter, let's say.
And there's none of that
in Marilynne's lectures.
So I thought, if you
wouldn't mind, Marilynne--
and of course you
should feel free exactly
to answer as little or
as much as you want to.
But I thought, if
you wouldn't mind,
we could just start
at the beginning
with your childhood in Idaho.
You've talked a lot about the
importance of public education
and of libraries.
But I actually wanted to
ask you about the sort
of religious atmosphere
you were brought up in
and the development
of that sensibility
as you got into your teens.
- My family was not
particularly churchy.
Let's put it that way.
I never doubted that
they were religious.
I felt as if--
I mean, I didn't talk
about my religious thinking
either until I was, what,
through college, probably.
I've never felt inhibited
or urged or coerced
or anything like that.
I had a very quiet family, and
I was a quiet participant in it.
And we were living
in a glorious place.
And I read whatever
interested me.
And I wouldn't change
any of it, you know?
- Yeah.
- I was at a religious college
a few days ago, Wheaton College.
And they pointed out
that I had said somewhere
that it was not
my family's habit
to say grace before meals.
You have to be careful what
you confide to an interviewer.
I felt suddenly rebuked.
[LAUGHTER]
- Was there a moment where--
I mean, given that background--
and I don't want to
reduce everything
to some sort of 19th
century religious dilemma.
But it seems, given
that background,
you could, as it were,
have gone either way.
Did you have a sense in
your late teens or 20s
of adding to whatever
religious inheritance you had,
of being unfolded
in a way that was
more intense than your parents?
- I was interested,
in the first place,
in religion as a metaphysics.
I was interested in
it as a worldview.
I don't know when this began.
Religious thought never seemed
to me separate from thought
itself.
And it was a very
natural path for me
to follow farther and farther
into for exactly those reasons.
It always felt to me as if
there were a soundness to it
and, at the same time,
an openness to it.
I think, often, people
who are brought up
in religious
atmospheres, they often
feel constrained by what
they have been taught.
But to me, it always
seemed like it
raised absolutely the largest
questions, the most interesting
questions.
And so I was propelled
autonomously, in effect,
in the direction that
was very natural to me.
- Yeah.
You've said, I think, about
your novel Housekeeping,
which, by my
calculation, is taught
on at least four
courses here at Harvard,
which is fairly astonishing.
It used to be a fair bet that
you could say that the only two
novels that any of the
students will have read
were Lolita and
To the Lighthouse
because they were all taught
on overlapping courses.
But now, I think we have to
add Housekeeping to that.
I teach Housekeeping.
I love that book.
And I know you've
described it as being,
in some way, an accounting
for and a summation
of the kind of--
that you wanted to work
with the materials that
were available to you as a
child growing up in Idaho.
That's to say, the kind of
things you would have learnt
at school, the
natural resources.
And of course, that's a
beautiful element in the book.
In some ways, I
think the book is
about the construction
of a religion out
of the available
bits and pieces,
including school textbooks and,
quite literally, twigs and soil
and water.
Can I ask you, when you
were writing Housekeeping,
when you wrote it and how you
went about writing that novel?
- Well, I wrote a
dissertation on Shakespeare.
And when I was
doing that, people
told me that if you
wrote that sort of thing,
you would not also
write a novel.
We're here to contest that view.
But in any case, so as I
was writing my dissertation,
I was writing
extended metaphors.
And my interest in
extended metaphors
came directly from 19th
century American literature.
So I think you can see
the allusions that I'm
making in Housekeeping.
But I wrote these things,
and they were in a stack.
And I realized that I actually
had made the core of something
or the beginning of something.
And then I went
to France to teach
in an exchange for a year.
And while I was there, the
university went on strike.
What could I do?
The building was locked.
What can I say?
But in any case, so I
was living in this house
out in the French countryside.
And I was considered a novelty.
And so the little kids that
lived in the neighborhood
would come over and pound on
my windows to see me move.
I mean, that was literally it.
We would wave.
So I went into a back
room in that house,
and I closed those big shutters.
And that made the
room absolutely dark.
And I had a little, wobbly
bedside lamp, and a spiral
notebook, and a black pen.
And I began writing, continuing
what I had done before.
And it was very interesting
and valuable to me
because I was in what
amounted to a sort
of sensory deprivation
environment.
And I was--
I've already told this
story this morning.
But anyone who heard
it before, forgive me.
I would be plunging
around in my memory,
trying to remember Idaho.
I hadn't lived there
for, like, 17 years.
I found that I had, over
time, an extraordinary success
remembering Idaho.
And this acquainted
me with the fact
that my mind was much larger
than my customary access to it
would let me know, that my
memory was very, very much
fuller and more precise
than anything that I
would have imagined.
I'm pleased.
Sometimes-- there are all
these mountain systems there--
Bitterroot, and bannock and all
these kinds of [? cabinet ?]
and so on, [INAUDIBLE].
And people would write to me and
say, which mountains, asking--
they had had an argument
about which mountains
I was referring to, which
pleased me very much.
But in any case, I found my way
into that novel in that way.
And over time, I
wrote it, as it were,
long story short, as they say.
But when I came back to
America, a friend of mine
had written and
published a novel.
And he asked if he could see
my novel, and I gave it to him.
And he sent it to his
agent, didn't tell me.
So out of a blue sky, I
got a letter from an agent
saying she would like
to represent my book.
She's still my agent.
But people ask me how to
enter the literary world.
I have no idea.
[LAUGHTER]
- Fantastic.
It feels to me like a different
novel from your later books.
And obviously, there
can be reasons for that.
One would be that
there was a long gap
between the next three.
Another is that the next three
belong together in some way.
But the prose also
seems different.
And I understand when you say
that the first book came out
of a thing of writing,
experimenting, in a way,
with long metaphors.
I mean, you can see that
in the book, of course.
It's absolutely part
of the fabric of it.
When you came to fiction again--
it's rather assuming that
you hadn't in between.
But as it were, when you were
next writing fiction, whenever
that was, was it the
same kind of prose?
Did it feel like the
same kind of prose,
or did you feel, OK, that was
a particular pinnacle that I
reached and a
different kind of place
that I want to be now in
terms of just the style?
- Well, when I was working on
Housekeeping, one of the things
that bothered me is
that a great deal
of contemporary
literature, things
that I read about in
the newspaper and so on
at that time, seemed to me to
be incredibly conventional--
thin characters
and tired language.
And so I thought, well, I can
retreat into my own enclave.
Nobody has written about
my little part of Idaho.
And so I had the
whole thing to myself,
whatever kind of language
and association and so on I
wanted to explore.
But then 24 years passed.
And then I was out on the
cape, waiting for my sons
to join me for Christmas
in an empty hotel.
And John Ames
spoke into my mind.
I don't know what that means.
I got-- the first sentences of
Gilead simply occurred to me.
They had the heft of
a novel behind them.
And so I wrote on from there.
Voice is what
determines my style.
I don't know.
I couldn't go back to
the character of Ruth
or the problems of Ruth, so I
couldn't go back to her prose
either.
- Right, that makes
a lot of sense.
Is there another way, though,
in which that first novel is
different from the later ones?
Or maybe I'm just
trying to find things
that I'm determined to find.
But it seems to me that if
we could say of the trilogy--
I mean, you're never an
orthodox writer, religiously.
But if we can say of the Gilead
trilogy, that it's more--
I think one could
fairly say that it's
more obviously located in a
set of recognizable Christian
traditions, should we say.
What's very striking
about Housekeeping
is this flood-like
paganism that seems
to be about to inundate
everything and sweep away
everything.
Or put it another way,
what's remarkable to me
when I reread it,
when I teach it,
is what you call the
resurrection of the ordinary.
The spring, just walking
through a forest and spring
about to happen or
happening, is a strong rival
to any orthodox religious
spiritual resurrection
that there might be in the
novel, such a strong rival
that it might even outdo
it, if that makes any sense.
In other words, I feel
that novel is really--
when I said earlier that
it's about the construction
of a religion, I meant that
in the sense of with all
the possible heresies and
impurities, as it were,
that might happen
when you just decide
to construct a religion
out of what's at hand.
When you look back,
does it feel different
in that theological sense?
- I think of it
as an exploration
of what is called natural
religion, the sort of chapter
1 of Romans, you know?
- Yeah.
- I mean, in a way, I
recapitulate my childhood
because I did, in a sense,
put my religious consciousness
together out of experience
rather than out of instruction
and ideas like resurrection.
And so I remember
how strange, how
almost daunting, or something,
those ideas seemed to me when
I was a child to the extent--
I mean, you hear of the
word, and you sort of
have the image in mind.
But I'm interested in the
theology of the uninstructed.
Ruth is one example,
and Lila's another.
I think that a
great deal of what
one could describe as
religious understanding
is sensitivity to
what is implicit.
- Yeah, yeah.
Can I just talk to you for
a second about resurrection?
I think it's your great
abiding obsession.
You have a few, but that's
a really powerful one.
It's there in all the books.
Sometimes, it's figured as
home and the return to home.
Often, as justice--
and you're equally
interested in political justice,
the restoration of the healing
and restoration that's
necessary on earth as much as it
is in heaven.
But this is a constant
element in your writing,
what you beautifully call
the lore of completion.
In Housekeeping, you
say where everything
will be made comprehensible.
What are all these fragments for
if not to be knit up finally?
And then some of you might
remember, in Gilead, there's
this fabulous thing that I often
return to that John Ames says
about the famous
verses from Revelation
about how, when we reach
heaven, God will wipe away
all our tears, and
there shall be no more
death, neither crying
or sorrow, verses
which obsessed another
heaven-obsessed writer,
Dostoevsky.
John Ames, glossing
those verses,
writes, "It takes nothing from
the loveliness of the verse
to say that is exactly
what will be required."
So there is a great
deal of suffering,
and a great deal of healing will
be needed to make up for that,
compensate for that suffering.
As you can probably tell, I'm
fairly obsessed with this too.
The problem is I
can't believe it.
And what I love
about your work is
that it's also
full of people who
they believe it more
than I do, and they want
to believe it more than I do.
But in your writing,
it's also hedged around
with a great deal of
necessary doubt and anxiety.
And I respond to that very much
as the kind of reader I am.
And I really just wanted
to talk to you about that.
That's a little vague, isn't it?
All right, let me just
ask you about this lovely
"It takes nothing from the
loveliness of the verse
to say that is exactly
what will be required."
- Well, as far as
resurrection is concerned,
just to back away from
the question for a moment,
I think of it in terms
of there being what I
think of as a human over plus.
I think of people as being much
too profound, much too complex,
much too open to the extremes
of experience to simply live
fourscore years and die.
I mean, in that sense,
just on humanist grounds,
it seems almost inevitable to
think that there is more to us
than perishes in this world.
This has been very
important to me
from the point of view
of characterisation,
just to be technical
about it, but you know.
So often characters, seem
almost thrown away in fiction.
They seem dismissed.
And I feel as though that's
always, always inappropriate,
that it is simply
authorial neglect.
I think that--
I mean, on that
basis, I don't come
at resurrection doctrinally.
I come at resurrection
like, that certainly
seems right to me.
I think that if there's a
reality that is humane enough
to super-induce life from
us, I think it would also
be attentive to our tears.
And it would reflect
the existence of a God
who is attentive to them who
would make the very tender
fatherly gesture.
- Unfortunately,
as you know well--
and you write about this,
and you imply it often
in your essays.
The promise of a
spiritual restoration
can get in the way of actual
material political restoration.
That is to say, it can
be one of the curses,
I think, of a certain
kind of religious charity,
is that instead of the
here and now, there
is an emphasis on the
then and the future.
Is that fair?
Am I characterizing--
- I think that can be true.
I am a Calvinist
because I read Calvin,
and he persuaded
me of many things.
But one of the things
he said is that if God
wanted us to know
anything about heaven,
we'd know something about it.
The fact that we don't
know anything about it
means we have to pay
attention to what we can know,
which is this world, this life.
And so I don't--
I mean, I have a
religious resistance,
that he named for
me, to imagining
a life beyond this one.
I'm very happy to concede the
possibility or the likelihood.
But in terms of the specifics,
I expect to be surprised.
- Of course, your
fiction is full of people
who are imagining,
in often quite
hilarious, practical
physical detail,
going right back to the
beginning of Housekeeping,
or right through, I
think, to your last novel,
and indeed, to that
wonderful essay, I think,
where you talk--
I can read the very
beginning of it.
Where is it now?
It's the one about
hope where you
talk about someone who was at
church with you who suddenly
said, if heaven
exists, she would
like to go up and take the
hand of her grandmother,
or something like that.
It's very nice.
I've got to try and find it.
But yeah, going right
back to Housekeeping
when I think Ruth's
grandmother is
said to expect that heaven will
look quite a lot like Idaho.
And of course, these are
ordinary human desires.
You're brilliant at
writing about them.
Do you have them yourself?
I mean, do you fall
prey to them yourself?
I mean, you said
just now, you feel
you shouldn't be imagining
heaven as anything
just as more than a surprise.
But do you actually
do the same things
that your characters
do, which is think, oh,
that's where I'll see
my mother, that's where
I'll see my father, and
they'll look like this,
and the room will
be such and such?
- I can't really--
my imagination stops at the
point of whom I would encounter
and under what circumstances.
I mean, the great--
it's like the
question that Jesus
has asked of somebody who
has seven husbands, who's
wife is she.
And we are so entangled
with one another that--
I mean, I might want
to see my mother,
but then her sisters
might have a prior claim.
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
I take it to be unfathomable.
And to the extent
that I talk about it,
I'm usually sort of
literalizing assumptions
that I would not directly share.
I assume it would be wonderful.
That's certainly its reputation.
But I--
[LAUGHTER]
Beyond that, I just hesitate--
you know what I mean?
I find the image problematical.
I do always have
people walking out
of the lake and all
that sort of thing.
But that's only her
saying, how can we
imagine the life that has
fallen into this lake,
and how can we imagine
its [? purdurability? ?]
- Yeah, yeah.
The thing from
your essay, "Hope,"
is, "In church, a
lady so tiny with age
that when she stood up, her hat
was just visible above the pew,
said, 'The first thing I'll
do when I get to heaven,
I'll run and find my grandma.
She loved me so much.'
Her small voice crackled
with anticipation."
But it's a very humane
vision you have, I think,
because you see that--
I mean, what I love
about it is when
I was trying to
work this stuff out
to my satisfaction as a
teenager and in my early 20s,
I abstractly, I
suppose, abstractly came
to a number of decisions about
the impossibility of heaven,
beginning with the
idea that heaven
was the great problem
for [? theolocy, ?] not
the solution to
it, but containing
such questions as
precisely the ones you deal
with humanely in your fiction.
That's to say, continuity.
It can't be just
like it is on earth.
If it were, we'd all be
doing exactly, up there,
what we do here, which
would mean, of course,
that it's like Eden.
We would be spoiling it with
error and sin and freedom.
So it can't be the same
as it is down here.
But so that's continuity.
But difference is
also the problem.
Because if it's
too different, it
doesn't seem to have any of the
pleasures that life here has,
and we can't imagine it.
And the unimaginability is,
I think, part of the problem.
And then adequacy, which goes
back to the beautiful John Ames
thing, "It takes nothing
from the loveliness
of the verse to say that is
exactly what will be required."
Adequacy, how does salvation,
healing, restitution,
the law of completion,
how could it ever
compensate adequately for
the suffering that many of us
have to put up with on earth?
- Well, one can
only assume it can.
I mean that it is
of a kind that does.
I think that a long life, in
retrospect, seems very brief,
she said, speaking
as one who knows.
I'm sure that in the
temporal scale of the cosmos,
all of our lives will
seem extraordinarily
brief to the point
of disappearance
from assuming any
kind of other life.
There is no way to--
I mean, if you remove the
idea of an embracing God
who nevertheless presides over
a world in which suffering
is very, very common
and always has
been-- god bless our ancestors.
But if you remove that,
then what you have
is simply suffering, about
which nothing can be made.
You can't even say, then,
what a terrible thing it
is that a human being
should live so briefly
or live so painfully.
Because then, we lack the
sanctifying definition
that makes our suffering
matter in the universe.
And we have to believe it does.
- Yeah, I suppose.
Well, one could
argue that what you
have without the promise
is just the suffering, yes,
without the false
promise, shall we
say, of restoration, which
would then force you,
one, to concentrate on
the restoration here
and now, I suppose.
But again, what I like
about your fiction
is the way in which it's
alive to these doubts
and uncertainties, the
tendency to overliteralized.
And it's also alive to the
fact that if one idea of heaven
is going home, Eden,
going back to the place
that you came from, your
characters don't really
want to be there.
I mean, if you think
of Ruth and Sylvia
at the end of Housekeeping,
they're wanderers.
Jack Boughton comes home, is the
prodigal son, but leaves home.
And the constant-- what
I love about [INAUDIBLE]
is that she's always
about to take off, right?
You're not sure at
the end of the novel
whether she's even
going to stay,
even though you know from the
earlier novels that she must.
I like that a lot.
I think that you're
wonderfully alive to that.
And I suppose this is
a way of asking you
whether you feel that--
I suppose it must be the case--
that writing fiction helps
you to dramatize, stage,
work certain things out in a
way that, say, writing an essay
might not.
- Well, that's certainly true.
That is certainly true.
Writing fiction is
another way of thinking
that is satisfying to me.
Also, the feeling of following
a thought to its conclusion--
it's just in another
dialect, in effect.
Well, it's quite other.
But when you talk about the
improbability of heaven,
how improbable is this life?
It's 99% anti-matter,
100% matter,
emerged from the
Big Bang, right?
That's the theory.
We exist because there is that
tiny failure of equivalence
between these two things.
I mean, you can go through--
I'm not using an argument
from design or anything.
I'm just saying that this
world in this universe
is such an improbable thing.
And if you were
back at moment one
and someone said, well,
here are some protons
and here are some neutrons,
put a world together
to be populated by creatures
that love poetry, you know?
- That's absolutely true.
I can't deny that.
Nevertheless--
[LAUGHTER]
Nevertheless, if you look
at the very narrative arc
that we are given as Christians,
say, from the Hebrew Bible,
it would suggest surely that--
and your own fiction
rather plays into this--
that home isn't the
place we return to.
Home is the place
we always leave,
right-- that there may
be an Eden somewhere.
But if we get to it,
we'll almost as soon
have to leave it,
that we're always
leaving rather than going back.
That, as it were, to adapt
that terrifying Kafka
line about there is infinite
hope, but not for us,
there is a law of
completion, but not for us.
- Well, you'd have to prove it.
- [LAUGHS] Well, that remains
to be seen, doesn't it?
- Yes, it does.
- Neither of us will know.
- We're all
interested observers.
- Let me ask you
another question.
We're on this thing of doubt or
whatever we're talking about.
You do talk about doubt, and
you have done in your essays.
And of course, I love the
dynamic in your essays,
that on the one
hand, you're quite
good at bringing the hammer down
when it needs to come down--
say, defending Calvin
or Jonathan Edwards
or something like that.
And it's good work.
And it's an
instruction to read it.
And you're also very
good at giving space
to your liberal Christianity,
which is liberal in this also
sense of having doubt.
So I suppose a question, which
is an impertinent one, perhaps,
but one I would like to
ask you is, when you doubt,
what do you doubt?
- Well, I'd say
here, again, I think
I'm a Calvinist because
my family were Calvinists,
but they'd forgotten it already.
But I have always
considered doubt
to be a dielectric with faith.
He says that, that you slip back
because your assumptions are
too narrow.
And then being
instructed, I doubt
you'd make another experiment of
thought or belief or whatever.
So I have not ever dealt with
doubt as being a problem.
I've always seen it as--
I mean, sometimes you--
I don't know.
I haven't doubted in
quite a long time.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll tell you the truth.
I consider my life
to be completely
unanticipateble by me.
I wrote a book I thought
would never be published,
and I get a letter in
the email from an agent.
I mean, that's sort of
the image of my existence.
I find it fantastic.
I'm supposed to be one of the
hundred most influential people
in the world.
Even, what, Time
Magazine said that,
and they're never wrong, right?
- Never.
- I mean, this is just
grossly improbable.
And it has--
- They got Trump
right so many times.
- So anyway, I feel as though
I know what I want to do,
which I consider to
be a great blessing.
So long as my faculties
hang together,
I will do what it seems
to me as if I ought to.
I'm content with that.
I'm much more than content--
amazed at the
opportunity, frankly.
- Between Housekeeping
and Gilead,
you were writing essays.
And you may-- also,
you will tell me--
have been writing fiction.
Why were you writing essays, and
so many essays, in that period
and not, at least,
publishing fiction?
- I wasn't writing fiction.
I had a crisis, a crisis
you might call a doubt.
After I finished
Housekeeping, which
I liked and I was pleased with
the reception of it and so on,
but I felt as if I had
solved a problem in a way
that it would be
dishonest to repeat.
I could not use the
same solution again.
I did not want to be
regional in the sense
that I could not move
beyond my region.
And I realized, frankly,
that my education,
as much as I valued
it, was really
only an annotated bibliography.
I just knew what I had--
I had a general sense
of what I should know
and no great confidence that I
knew it in any meaningful way.
So I went-- the luxury, I spent
24 years basically reading,
reading things like
The Wealth of Nations,
Malthus' theory of population,
Capital, every book
that everyone had always
spoken to me about as if they
had read it.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was a new territory.
It was a-- you know what I mean?
And once you start
doing that, then there's
no natural stopping place.
I just stopped finally because
I had this novel in my mind.
But to the extent
I've stopped, I'm
still reading all
kinds of strange things
by other people's standards.
But I could not repeat the
northwestern provincial style.
Don't ever quote that.
[LAUGHTER]
And I could not write anything
else with the confidence
that I myself was
actually saying this.
And so I did a great
deal of very basic work
in order to feel that my
thoughts were, in some degree,
my own.
And of course, there are limits
to how much that's ever true.
But I felt, finally, as if I
could speak in my own right,
you know?
- Yeah.
And one conclusion you came
to, I know from that reading,
is the one that Liz quoted
in her introduction.
And it's in one of the
essays in the new book,
that the world is run,
not very well, according
to unread books.
One of them is the Bible.
Do you want to name another?
- Well, Capital is
certainly a good example.
And it's so odd.
I mean, frankly,
the same person that
sent my novel to his agent also
lent me his copy of Capital,
which I never returned.
But in any case, that's
embarrassing, but it's true.
But he writes in the
style of Martin Luther.
He does this because he was
reared as a Lutheran, right?
Who doesn't?
I mean, we are such--
what do you call it--
racists or something
that we assume that
we know everything
about this man because
of his, what, last name?
But in any case, when you
read him, having read Luther,
you can see what kind of
argument he's making and why.
I mean, and of course, this
is complicated by the fact
that they're a hundred
of years apart,
and there's the influences
of culture and so on.
But nevertheless, that's
something that's absolutely not
recognized in him.
He was dealing in the
language of social morality--
I mean, basic equity--
that you find in Adam Smith and
that you find in the tradition
that he felt that he--
he was writing for Germans.
So his polemical
methods would certainly
be influenced by the most potent
polemic that was ever launched
in the German language.
I mean, the sort of
de-contextualization
that people engage in,
which is dramatically
inappropriate to an
interpretation of his work.
The reason-- I mean, I sort
of started early with Marx
because I knew so many
Marxists, and I never
knew one who had read him.
[LAUGHTER]
- So once you were really
reading Marx, what conclusions
did you come to in terms of--
I mean, what were people
taking from the Marx
they weren't reading?
How was he getting
flattened down,
and what would it be
that you want to restore?
What would be most
important to talk
about now about our neglect
of actually really Marx?
What are we not getting there?
- Well, his argument
is basically
a recoil from the fact of
the extraordinary suffering
of the working class.
I mean, when-- what's his name--
Disraeli said that the lifespan
in Manchester, at that time,
was 15.
People could expect
to live to be 15.
And I mean, the routine,
mechanized brutality
of reducing populations
to that level, I mean,
that's where you have to
begin in understanding Marx.
And then I'm sure
we could find things
that are perfectly equivalent
in other parts of the world,
and certainly in the less
well-functioning parts
of this country.
So I mean, there's a
humanitarian core in Marx
that was turned into
some kind of, like,
industrial-age
machinery so that you
had this and that dialectic
going on and so on,
completely without
the moral ballast
that is absolutely
central to Marx himself.
- And this is generally, in your
essays, particularly when, say,
you write about the university,
but it's a strong current
throughout this book--
as I was reading it, I was
thinking how much you sound--
and I'm not the first
person to have said this,
I know-- but how much you
sound like certain 19th century
social critics.
There's a real prophetic
strain in your writing,
perhaps increasingly
emboldened, as you are,
by the last four or five years
of political developments.
But there's a strong
sound there of certain--
Marx would be one.
Ruskin might be
another, maybe even
Dostoevsky of Notes from
Underground-- an attack on what
you see as a stifling
pragmatism, utilitarianism,
a narrow economic
definition of both education
and of human potential.
And that's a powerful
note in your essays.
I know you talked somewhat to
President Obama about that.
But I'd sort of hoped,
in that interview,
that you and he would dig
a little further into that.
- Yes, well, it ended.
He was on a tight schedule,
and we were just getting
into the meat of things.
And then suddenly, operatives
come and scuttle him out
of the room.
It's the problem
talking with presidents.
[LAUGHTER]
- This is the first
moment where I
hear you taking justifiable
pride in your achievements.
- Actually, I'm going to
limit myself to one president.
[LAUGHTER]
- Yeah, well, it's
true that there's
a sad moment in that
wonderful exchange that
was published in the Review
of Books where Obama says--
or maybe it's elsewhere
that he says something
about how he picked
up Gilead when
he was campaigning in Iowa.
And he says something like,
there were long journeys
between campaign stops.
There's a lot of
down time to read.
I immediately think, well, not
with the current president.
That's just more
time to watch TV.
Maybe we should open
the questioning up
to the audience at this point.
We've got about 20
minutes, I think.
Here we go.
- Hi, I'm Patsy
[? Bodwin. ?] I'm
curious to know whether
your books are--
I assume your books
have been translated.
And I'm wondering what you
think of the reception you're
getting in any
countries that you would
want to speak to us about.
- My books have been translated.
My most recent
language is Icelandic.
I don't know.
I can't follow those
things particularly well.
But I assume, since
they keep getting
translated in places
like Iran and so on,
that they have a reasonable
history of life in translation.
I'm very grateful to think
that people are reading them
in other places.
- Hi.
My name is Sarah, and--
oh, this is very loud.
So my question is I guess
Calvinists kind of have
this reputation as being,
like, grumpy and boring,
which is not how I
think many people who've
read your books would
characterize them
or the people in them.
They're compassionate and funny.
And so I guess I'm
wondering, like,
why is it that people think
Calvinists kind of suck,
and why do the people
in your books not?
- Well, there are Calvinists
that deserve that reputation.
[LAUGHTER]
What can I say?
I mean, I think part of
my fascination with Calvin
is resurrection.
I'm trying to excavate him from
this burial under the worst
implications that people
have drawn from his writing.
Every major theologian,
including Ignatius Loyola,
has said, yes, there
is predestination.
The only two who
don't agree with this
is [? Chrysostom ?]
and John Wesley.
So how did it get
pinned on Calvin?
Polemic.
I think he had the
problem of being
the most effective polemicist,
the most effective theoretician
of his period.
And therefore, he took the
brunt of a lot of controversy.
That's a very complex
question I've brought up,
but nevertheless, things like
that that are artificially
associated with him as
if other people had not
come to the same conclusion.
And then there are just
inexcusable Calvinists.
[LAUGHTER]
- Hi, I'm Heather.
Happy to be here [INAUDIBLE]
I was [? thinking ?] when
you were talking about in
the absence of a caring God,
is our suffering meaningful.
And just a thought, so
I won't go on too long.
But I was thinking, for me as
a humanist, I feel like my job
as a human being is to
watch other people suffering
with at least watchful
concern and caring,
that that's what people
do for each other.
And then I think, as a
reader, the characters
I love the most
and the writers I
love the most, I feel like those
characters are sitting with me,
that they can sit and keep
me company in my suffering
without a God being here.
So I was just wondering what
you thought about humanism
as a way of approaching
giving meaning
to suffering even if I don't
feel a caring God is up there.
- Well, that makes suffering
a different kind of problem,
certainly.
I think that human freedom
is real in the sense
that we, from moment to moment,
have the option of dealing with
people with the degree of
respect that they yearn for.
A lot of suffering, I
think, is not visible.
I think that a huge
source of suffering
is the rationing of
respect that we engage in.
In other words, I
think that we are
given the real
problem of dealing
with the sad burden of human
sensitivity in all its forms,
and that the
question is actually,
are we going to
respond from the soul?
And that's one of the
existential questions
that we are burdened with or
dignified by as human beings.
- Hi.
My name is Linda
Schneider, and I
was introduced to
your writing in 1982
in the first fiction
course I have ever taken.
It was not an assigned book,
Housekeeping, at that time.
But Susan [? Mansker ?]
had really
read a story that
I wrote and said,
you have to read this book.
And I have read
it multiple times,
[? though ?] the religious
element, at that time,
just went right over my head.
But what I was deeply
moved by in the book--
and I think you
alluded to it when
you talked about authorial
respect for characters.
And that was there
was clearly something,
quote, unquote,
"wrong" with Sylvie--
or mental illness.
I don't know what
you want to call it.
But the respect accorded
her and the girls
and the sad history of the
family was very moving.
And I don't know if you had
encountered in your life
or in your town or
whatever, but what
made you just have such a much
larger vision of these people
than a lot of
writers might have.
- Well, I was talking
earlier about how,
reading contemporary
fiction at the time,
I couldn't find characters
that seemed real to me
that were complex enough.
And so my solution was to
do a kind of Cubist portrait
where Ruth--
in my mind, Ruth is one
profile, and Lucille is another,
and [? Sophie ?] is another.
It's Cubist.
But in any case, I
consider them to be--
I mean, I think everyone lives
not only with the choices we
have made, but with the
choices we have not made,
with the kind of
yearnings that we
have felt we had to suppress.
Where I lived, I think
one of the yearnings,
since there was just
wilderness all around us,
was that you could just
take off and just disappear
into nature in some way.
So I was rewarded, when I
tried to make, by my lights,
one character
richer, by the fact
that it seemed to make
all the characters richer,
in my experience.
So that's what was
happening there.
- Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE],, and
I'm a senior at the college
studying sociology.
So I love your fiction.
I'm a huge fan of your
fiction, but I also
love your essay collections,
The Death of Adam
and When I Was a
Child I Read Books.
And I was really struck by
the ideas of Old Testament
traditions and liberality and,
as you've been talking about,
restoration and resurrection.
And it resonated
with me not only
because you were very
convincing, but also
because of my own Protestant
traditions growing up.
But I wanted to ask
whether your ideas
on social justice, which have
been really compelling because
of this prophetic, religious
fire that you have,
whether religious thinking
is a foundational premise
for these social justice
ideas, or just the lens
through which you
look at issues.
So is God or religious
thinking a necessary condition
of your ideas, or is it
just one of many lenses
that you can have or
that any person can
have looking through
it, as a secular lens,
for instance, and reaching
the same conclusion?
- Yes, it's an
interesting question.
I think that there's a tendency
to think of religion as being
doctrinal and formulated.
I think there are lots
of people who would not
think of themselves
as religious,
but nevertheless, they
look at another human being
and they say, this is sacred.
We ought not to allow
this to happen--
a crowded prison, or any
of the infinite number
of things that we see.
I think that if you have an
intuition of the sanctity
of a human being so that
you want to give them
dignity and the
possibility of living out
their lives by their
lives and so on,
that is basically a
religious impulse.
It's just non-doctrinal,
non-denominational.
- But it could-- just to leap
in, but it could be there's no
reason why it needs to
be grounded necessarily
in the notion of the divine.
- I don't know.
I mean, I think that you
proceed from a different set
of assumptions that I do.
I think that if you see
the sacred in anything,
that is an intuition
of the divine.
It doesn't matter if
it's quantum physics
or your next-door neighbor.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
I was wondering
if you could speak
a little bit about
your experience
as a writing
instructor, what you've
observed in the classroom, the
different mistakes students
have made, promising
aspects of what's emerging
from writing programs today.
- Oh, a great deal is
emerging now, a great deal.
I see a lot of students
making the mistake that I did,
which is the idea that you can
look at what is being written
in your moment and
feeling as though you have
some obligation
to it or as if you
will fall into a stream
of the publishable
or something like that.
And, I mean, if you're
trying to do that,
then you're making yourself
second-rate, in effect.
It's incredibly difficult
to do, but people
have to find their own voices,
as everybody tells you,
but they tell you the truth.
The workshop, at
the moment, it's
going through an
interesting transition
because finally, we have
a diversity of students.
For such a long
time, people will not
apply to come to
Iowa because it's
Iowa, which is a lovely state.
I mean, it's just a--
but anyway, this has ended now.
So we're getting a lot of kids
that are first generation, kids
from the Caribbean, and so on.
And people like that
have the advantage
of making a case for the
world they come from.
And so they're very attentive
to the kind of beautiful details
of life that most of us only
notice when you stop and think,
well, this is a beautiful,
sunlit day here,
even in the middle
of the Middle West.
So there's a kind of
richness that is coming in,
and an attentiveness to detail--
you're great on detail--
that is a tremendous
[? balloon. ?]
We're seeing a lot
of interesting stuff.
It diversifies the voices.
It makes everybody more
conscious of what they're there
to do.
It's a very good thing.
- Hi, my name is Abigail.
And I was curious about
the role of reading.
So it seemed as
though you articulated
that you wanted to read widely
before returning to fiction,
or it seemed somehow necessary
to develop a new sense of self
as a writer.
But it didn't seem like you had
that same feeling about writing
nonfiction in essays.
And I'm wondering about the role
of that kind of wide reading
in both of those
voices, and also
whether there's a different
sort of sense of position
that comes when you write
nonfiction and fiction
and how voice differs there.
- Well, my essays,
they're usually lectures.
And they're usually very much
as I delivered the lecture.
And what they usually
are, I'm usually
speaking to a college
or sometimes a church.
They're little
screams of surprise.
This is what you've
been led to believe.
This is not true.
And it's based on some
book I've been reading
or some literature
I've been reading.
And so the essays, up
until very recently--
and perhaps recently also--
are rooted directly in
my going back and looking
at things that,
frankly, were things
that were misrepresented to me.
- Hi, my name is John.
My question has to do with the
sense of religiosity or faith
or kind of a belief in a
divine or something mysterious.
I'm curious to know--
and this is something
that I had experienced when
I was in college, too--
whether it comes from a kind
of intellection or thinking,
or it comes from
experience, or it
comes from experience
that is kind of everyday
and really not through
kind of a logical faculty.
Where do you see that situated
within our mind and soul
and in other parts of our body?
- I think I have a more sort
of holistic sense of thinking.
I mean, some of the craziest
writing in the world
is writing that has taken
itself to be severely logical.
And I think that experience, if
you're functioning attentively,
experience feeds so directly
into every other aspect
of your thinking and in
your dreams and so on.
I think that if you isolate
something like intellection,
you are robbing it of its
primary resources, which
are all the other things
that you have named that also
come into the experience.
I think that we
are, for one thing,
acculturated to exclude
from our thinking
what we take to be imaginative,
as if imagination didn't
discover a thousand things that
science has adopted, and so on.
Also, I think we
live in a time when
the notion of what religion
is is strange enough
to drive people away
from it because it's
settled so strangely
in a great many minds.
It tends to be a claim
that you make for yourself
rather than an obligation
you feel for yourself,
that sort of thing.
I think that if you just
sort of relax and think,
my mind is my mind, and
it's so interesting,
and here I am with it.
And I will watch it live,
and it will watch me live--
I always start out
telling my students
that the human brain is the
most complex object known
to exist in the universe,
which is simply true.
You can read it in
Scientific American.
[LAUGHTER]
But if you think about that,
that every skull in this room
has, in it, this primary object
of cosmic life, then you think,
well, I have it.
Now what do I do with it?
Or what does it
do with me I think
is a more important question.
I think that you shouldn't
be passive in relation to it,
and you shouldn't try to do the
procrustean thing of making it
into something that is
useful to a industry
rather than being the
unbelievable cosmic privilege
of having that brain, that mind.
- May I ask a
follow-up question?
For someone who is
perhaps interested in kind
of grasping the sense of
unfathomable or mystery
or finding interest
in religion, do
you have any words
of encouragement?
[LAUGHTER]
Or if it's not just coming
from sitting in a room
and thinking on your own,
where does one find it?
How did you find that sort of
encounter or understanding,
if you can put it that way?
- I haven't used conventional
methods, obviously.
I think that-- what can I say?
People come to it by unique
ways, I think, very often.
If there's anything
that you consider
to be overwhelmingly
beautiful or amazing,
that gives you a taste of it.
If I want to have a full-blown
religious experience that's
as good as reading the psalms,
it's Scientific American.
I love these
beautiful hypotheses
about the beginnings of
things and the configuration
of the universe and all this.
It is so hyperbolic.
I mean, the Earth is
not a speck of dust.
And here we are,
looking at all this.
It's absolutely amazing.
I mean, that's my little
testimony to human beings
as being totally
unaccountable creatures.
But the things, the fact of
the materiality of things
looked at closely disappear
under the gaze, all of that
is very beautiful.
And for me, it's
very theological.
- Hi, my name is Bree.
And as a reader,
in my experience,
a lot of contemporary
literature tends
to be characterized by
a sense of hopelessness.
And as a lover of
stories, wanting
to capture this really
powerful sense of awe and joy
without it being seen as, like,
a lack of depth or something
that's naive, I think
in your stories,
you really capture
the balance of having
this deep, real sense of reality
and this deep sense of sadness
with this really real
experience of joy.
And as a writer, I
guess, how do you
strike that balance
between those two
and have it be believable?
And I guess, the follow-up
question would be too,
like, what do you
see the role of hope
in literature moving forward?
- Well, I think that
it has to be authentic.
You know what I mean?
I don't think that you can
induce in yourself something
you don't yourself feel.
You can work towards
something you don't feel.
That's always valuable.
I think that finding the balance
between anything and anything
else-- when you're writing,
every question is real.
Every moment is
another question.
How do I do this?
There is no solution that's
external to the specific work
that you are doing.
I think that one of the
things that really helps
is respect for your
characters, that you don't
embarrass them or abuse them.
Or you know what I mean?
I think that maybe readers take
a certain amount of reassurance
from the fact that they
are also not being abused.
They're not being lied to.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Hi, there.
My name is Catherine.
My question is, are
there ways that you
would recommend to us
to better cultivate
graciousness in our lives?
- To cultivate graciousness?
- Yeah.
- Well, I mean, I so
admire the project.
I mean, I think
that that would be
the answer to so many problems.
But you have to notice
it when you see it.
You have to be aware that
you have an occasion where
you yourself can enact it.
I think one of the
things that we don't do--
I talk about Calvin
and the human being
on the stage with God
watching and so on.
But we have, individually
in our own lives,
the continuing possibility
of acting well;
thinking not, what do I
need or what do I want,
but what's gracious
in this moment.
I think that's really the
discipline, to be aware of,
in terms of the sort of whole
canvas of human dignity,
how could I make a
decent account of myself
in this moment?
How can I do
something beautiful?
That's what I would say.
- Thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Well, that was really
an inspiring conversation.
[APPLAUSE]